εφτάθηλητες μέσα στο πρόγραμμα και το ικσκοστέεα δέκα θελητές μέσα στο πρόγραμμα εκτον οποίον οι
τρεις πιαστον υμακούς ικόνας αντονίος στην κολύμηση καια πάλι οι δύο ιστιοπλό μαριλένα μακρύ και
ναλα άλάθα που προανάφερα αλλά αυτή είν φοράν θέλμε να μαζέψουμε περισσότερα χρήματα και κάναμετον
κάλαντηνερ που κάναδύο του φευράλι με την παρουσία και του προεδρουου της δημοκρατίας τνα πάρα
πολύ πε δυχημένι βραδιά οποία α στημησία μαζέψαμε σχενών εκατοχι για δες ευρ και από
αυτά τα χρήματα ολι ιδεκαθλητες στηρικτηκαν μετάμσηγιάδες ευρώ οι τρεις που πήα ν υπρόκριση πήρα
επιπρόσεξε τα δύομιση γιάδ συμπροθήκαν ιδέκα καληφθηκαν κατάξειότα των εφτάθλητών που ήταν γίδη και αυτάαπρά
προσθέσει τι κανακόμα τρης για τις πρετιμασίας του του κοστία και έμεινα μερικά χρήματα που
θα βοηθήσει να ξεκινήσει το τός ελέε είμάστε στην κύπρο μικρή χώρα μια μικρή κοινωνία
ζής των αθλητισμό χρόνια θεωρίςω ότι ακόμα και σε αυτά σε αυτά τα θλήματα που
είναι ένα θαθητηναιομαικα υπάρχουν κυκλώματα τα οποία κόβουν ταων ιραθλιτών για να προχωρήσουν κάποιο άλληκοιταξε
αυτή είναι μια συζητήση που έτσιμπορά που εμ πολύ πια βαθιά στο σύστημα που υπάρχει
στυκήπον και τα όπως θαμπορεσε νανα είναι πιστεύω εγώ η μεγάλη δι αφορά που έχουμε
αό τις χώρες που συνεχώς βγάζουν πρωταιες ιολημπιονήκες περισότεροντες μεγάλες χώρες είναι να αυτές οι
χώρες έχουν τημιορήσι ένα σύστημα το οποίο χρησιμοποιού το βελτιώνυ και κάθετές στα χρόνια κάθε
οτώχρ ε κάθε τογαχρόνια υπάρχει μια μεγάλη ευερθίωση και φαίνεται εμείς δις θεώς δεν έχομε
σύστημα καιτί εννοσύστημα διαι από από μιανη λιγιάν από κτομια χρόμπου θα ξεκινήσει ένα παιδεί
ίνα άθλημα μέχρι